えっぱねじゃあはじめ雪をです皆さんドミノピザ知ってますでしょうかドミノピザさん
結構挑戦的でしてチーズがめちゃくちゃ多いピザとかぴこスノーなんでしょ
a みたいななんでショットあの池歩くするとバカにしてんじゃねーか的な編入をよく
出させるんですけど今回またとんでもないメニューきました
普段ドミドっていうですねドミノピザの裏メニュー的な感じであるんですけど今回もで
着きますやりすぎたすぐにね
いやああすげえ裏ドミノっていうんですねやめちゃくちゃいいやばいじゃん
欲望を裏で解き放てお客様のご要望に応えた最強ペット最強サイドメニューが浦富のと
して期間限定で販売開始どみんなで定番人気のピザ用紙に通常の2倍のガーリック3倍
の甘いフェーズを使った欲望の塊9月のポテト小枝が愛するポテトラバーに捧ぐ
1kg パッド3グループポテトはいまあここでは山ですよ末期里金アジないの
マリクマスター禁断の炭火焼きビーフ値段高いときの高齢化でここらへんのないのピザ
わかるんですけども問題はぽ体とこれで3kg ポテトぐらい
[音楽]
どうやってくれてんだこれ1曲だろポテトくらいもあるんですけどまぁ1今日はまだ
まあまあ分かりますよありますあります
3 k
やってる車
ちょっと自分がどれだけポテト距離勝手な好きにやってとこあるんでちょっとサイン
キログラム挑戦してみたいと思いますね自粛中に結構食う量が増えたんでよかったら
絶対来ま
ちょっとは言えないんですけど36な努力メイクいうのがちょっと挑戦できる人も超え
てやってみたいと思います中はセットを注文したいんですけど
ネットその裏ドミノってありますよ
あっあのポテトのあの3kg ですよ
ん
それで他の人結構いるんですか
[音楽]
はいはいうん
何バッティングはい密陽にはい大丈夫ですあいにゃんが人間になっていたけれどねぇ
入っございますん
配置でします終わったいや3キルっいや1キロだったらまだ分かるんですけども3キロ
のポイントなんですよ見たことないんでずっ元ビビってますねそれでまま自分の限界に
挑戦することに意味があると思うので食べてみたいと思いますね良い
[音楽]
はいでかい本当にデカイんですよとあるぞうわぁをもう伝わりにくいと思うけど本当に
デカイですよこれはちょっと開けてみますね
すごいてをの前4分くらい
[音楽]
いやーやいやはやこれはやりすぎですが見れなく普通にお箸の大きさがうまくれず
メイドするともうこのレベルですね
いやーなんかとピングっぽいなぁすべてねもうちょっと本当に尋常じゃない量ですね
これが道民のビデオのために3キロ接種1回ちゃんと体重を量ってみます
いっ
ふふふ
うんマジだ
またこれ3期の所じゃなくね3.6もある平野この容器だけで600だがないでしょ
血圧を測ります
[音楽]
マジだ正式に測っても
3.6km ネオ表情宗教やまあまあまあまあこの
あっこが600g あったってことにしましょう次で3.6キログラムスタートです
ここから何キロ分私はポテトを受けることができるのでしょうか
いただけないうまいことはまつげ年じゃあな
世界一うまいまあまあは残念買ってねますちょっと頑張ろう
ん
[音楽]
すー
がうんまっっ4角ぐらいに味がばかりてるのかそれぞれ全部美味しいですねー
[音楽]
た
今んとこ a にクエリで行きませんまん
結構でかいでしょ
[音楽]
じゃあまだホッパでったもええ
e 4 c
10分経過しましたここらへん極端でっての
4日
指摘ポテトって鼻にくるね味変シンナークールでまだあつってではないです
頑張ります
dee
これ
やばい案とかからめっちゃ腹できますねまあなんてどこで買ったんだろうなんてよくた
が見てみますえっこれも食ったほうだと思うけどな
はバッハ結局で動けてチェックを食ってる
残り3キロ600g アクってますね
ああっいます頑張っております
う
ずん低下しましたあのぱねあ普通のポイントが違ってみてあぐら的な油がもうすごい
ですよ
皆さんの思ってよる鉄鉱あの青い d です相当あるリング1個1個すごいダメージ
うん挟むんですけどもうちょっとだけ頑張るそうなんで頑張ります
ん
簡潔にたちましたーーー
[音楽]
えっ
いやあこうあああああボヤが結局私はどれくらい食べてたでしょうか払ってみます
年か普通な食べ物だから持ついけそうだったんですけどあふらーないでね恋
味も濃いしうまいクランクのたくさんは境内になっていくんですね
もうを
2.6kg ということでぴったり
1kg がポテトてました
[音楽]
これ誰が食うん何人はまつげない方も5キロぐらい分ぐらいドテン買いだと思うんです
よ
いや3キロた分丈仁など絶対食えんですこれいやもうご覧の皆さん一人で食べようとは
決して思わないでくださいただ食べきれない量のポテトがあるんだったら自分の限界に
挑戦してみて自分ってポテトはどれぐらいクエイドかっていう計算するにはとても良い
画面だと思いました皆
rar
おいィ
[音楽]
blr